all right number two oh oh
i thought i was gonna get [ __ ] for
number two and i
will but no not as much as i'm about oh
if
if this is your number two then that
could only mean what your number one is
yes oh no yes way ted
yes way oh john i knew the risks
what's up reject nation greg and john
here again today
so we're gonna do a ranking of the dceu
movies so no joker just dceu movies
we're gonna do our own ranking john
wrote his list
i wrote my list and we're going by just
what our
favorites are order of that the ones
that connect with us most
i know there's a version of this list
that exists to you know
not subject yourself to the most amount
of crap in the world
i have no idea there's an objective
and it's not mine at least i know that
with mine too so i was like
uh i just gotta be honest writing this
list going i know what i'm supposed to
say
all we can do is be honest with
ourselves right i have no idea what he
put down and he has no idea what i put
down so in my hand
is his list and in his hand is
my list what we're gonna do is since we
know that any time even if we put down
the list
if we were like what's the one that
would get us the least hate we know that
we would right it's just the way these
list videos go
so i thought well we just take care of
that ourselves and give each other some
criticism
i'm gonna read off john's list and then
he's gonna read off
my list we have an unveiling method
we're going to do here
we're getting them bottoms up one at a
time we'll start with number nine
all right so john's number nine
pick is oh not mine
it's justice league oh boy justice
league huh
the joss whedon edition now there's all
this talk going around about
is zack snyder's justice league will
that be considered official canon with
the dceu
obviously i'm a supporter i'm thinking
that that it should
i do i'm already under the impression
that it ought to be all right so you
don't like justice league
no i mean honestly like it's fine and
stuff
i don't have really any attachments to
it and i don't know what would compel me
to
watch it again fair enough
fair enough what's what's my number nine
nine your number nine is
not is it's lower than mine a suicide
squad
i deliberated i almost put that in
number nine i mean
suicide squad is i i kind of hate that
movie
the first time i watched it i was like
it's all right
and then the second time i was like oh
man this is annoying and boring
all at once the only reason i didn't go
full on number nine with that was just
because even when i get a breath of it
i'm still like there's
there's an air cut or something there
are things about this i want to be
like it calls me back whereas justice
league doesn't really do that
fair enough i want it to be good even
though it's not good so john's eight
this should come as no surprise it's
suicide squad
wow wow i mean i guess the hot debate is
what is worse justice league or suicide
squad which is worse something that
makes you mad or something that you
don't care about
ah fair enough all right john what's my
number eight number eight drum roll
please
oh this is gonna be fun wonder woman
1984. didn't like that 1984.
i mean i like the rest of the movies
that we're about to say
literally suicide squad is the only one
i don't i'm like no i for sure don't
like that movie we're 84 i'm like
it's all right then i was thinking about
the other ones and i'm like oh yeah now
this movie just
i i really do teeter more towards not
liking it than i do liking it
did this teeter happen i was like i have
no
choice it's got to be wonder woman 1984.
and this just clinches that you
definitely think
justice league by joss whedon is a
better film
i do comment
below if you share this video i have way
more fun
we'll get into it later i'm talking
about yes number
seven oh seven for you is aquaman oh
funny what's why numbers number seven is
aquaman at least we can agree on the
okay see eye to eye on that it's
visually stunning but i feel
almost nothing when i watch that movie
yeah but
the visuals alone are just so wondrous
and breathtaking beautiful that i'm like
oh it's definitely better than the other
ones
and it's fun enough that you know you
can't exactly slag it off
yeah like everyone showed up it's pretty
it's just so
okay yeah in a lot of what it's actually
doing
the actual story and the plot and the
characters are okay the execution of the
movie just leaves me feeling kind of
void but whenever there's action i'm
very entertained yeah yeah and i'm like
the action is competently and
beautifully put together the visuals are
delight
so yeah that's not enough naked patrick
wilson all right let's see if our i
think our number sixes are different
the numbers whoa you put this low on the
list
i did this is going to be another
contentious oh yeah
yeah whoa john you know how much love
there is for this
i am and i knew how much what are you
thinking you dumbass i'm
thinking about all those seconds i spent
writing this list going should i flip
this with the one that's right above it
should i flip this with the one that's
right oh
johnny you let me down i know i know
it's bvs ultimate edition what's my
number six your number six
is is batman v superman
you really have me going i thought we
were about to disagree on this
trust me my list i had it folded over
and everything i think it's very
apparent i like dc more than you
and i know i'm going to get more crap
for what i put down than you did
look i don't know let's let's wait till
we get to the top but ah this heartens
me
this is a movie that improved greatly
for me on re on watching the extended
edition i'm going by the extended
edition just to be
transparent like i think the ultimate
edition is better than theatrical cut
the next five
i'm more likely to re-watch just for
pure enjoyment than i
am for like there's great things in bv
i've gone to bat defending this movie
already i gave it a lot of crap when it
first came out but especially when we
did the cinema wins video
i get i i defend this movie i like
things about it that a lot of other
people don't even like just to put that
out there
at the end of the day though i mean it's
a really dour dark film and i'm
less likely to re-watch it yeah i might
i might revisit it again
in mini series form i think it goes down
better that way
okay our number fives are definitely
different all right oh yeah
they are different yours is like
wow we're both gonna get crap for number
five i know i feel like we both
feel the same way about these individual
movies or something
that i want to say at the same time
yeah if you balance out our two opinions
they probably come out equal
that's so funny that you put this in
number five and i put that at number
five because these are easily too
shattered on movies
in the dceu and i mean like for me
anyway with wonder woman
like yeah there's a lot of flaws for
sure we've talked about them multiple
times on this channel however it did a
couple
things it reached for a couple things
that as of right now
really stood out to me and that i
applauded the dceu for reaching
for so i don't know the stuff i really
like about that movie i might be
compelled to watch again a little sooner
than
perhaps i go back to whoo really
yeah good for you good max lord is worth
the price of admission
it's worth wonder woman's price of
admission justice league for me
is just that joss whedon one is a live
action
saturday morning cartoon first time i
watched it i was like
i like this more than everyone else the
second time i watched on imax i made a
whole video about why i love this more
than everyone i
i have to go out there and say i think
the action scenes in wwe 84 are better
than justice league like there's really
no memorable action scene in justice
league for me
but i can't deny that i i have a lot of
fun when i watch
that frankenstein's monster that is
justice league if you want to tell me
what's
wrong with it i can't argue with you
like yeah no
let us know i want to know what's wrong
with it i don't know
i have so much fun though when i watch
that movie
i do think this this one is going to be
a major improvement and feel like an
actual
real piece of work not just
some random thing they had to get out on
time not a weirdly over color corrected
monstrosity i signed the petition for
this
a couple days after i saw the one i have
ranked number five let's see if our four
through one are the same
oh i'm excited now four you put
who did i put this i think i have the
same one shazam
g i almost put this at three believe it
or not well let's see what number three
is oh
god are we walking out with the same
list here no no
look at what you got madison madness now
man of steel number nine very bad then
the
the moments of truth are really gonna
come down to one and two
oh god i don't know i don't know man of
steel a lot of people i know will
probably put that at number one
i really a lot of people would i really
like that movie a lot number three is
not bad
yeah and it's got a nice sense of
gravity i like i like shazam a lot super
fun but man of steel has
a bit of added weight and it's uh my
favorite of the henry cavill appearances
i'm surprised by how in tune we are with
like we've had a lot of off-camera
conversations so i'm
i'm pretty surprised by how in sync we
are with majority of this list so far
man you might have a better dc overall
love and knowledge but we both
know a little about films all right
number two
oh oh i thought i was gonna get [ __ ] for
number two
and i will but no not as much as i'm
about oh if
if this is your number two then that
could only mean what your number one is
yes oh oh no yes way ted
yes way oh john i knew the risks when i
put
on the universe oh you you honest i i
respect respect because you knew
i knew i knew the sex respect
and i flip-flopped this a couple times
and then i went
you know i have to be honest with myself
it's so funny because i thought our
number one and two were gonna be exactly
the same
they almost were they so they were very
close to almost being i mean
one and two were really easy for me
i deliberately people already figured
out what
yours is do the math number two for john
is wonder woman that's right
wow more than your number one i'm so
surprised hey
look out man wonder woman's a terrific
absolutely great film and
uh you know i think it's for what okay
so what's
what's really quick all right number
it's pretty obvious what the next one my
number two
is birds of prey is my number one is
this number one
and my number one is wonder woman it
comes straight down to this if i was
going on the more objective end of the
spectrum and not
factoring in as much just my own
personal tastes as a film
fan and and even with my own personal
taste as a film fan this was a hard one
to inch out because part of me was going
wonder woman is such
a monumental moment i was moved during
that movie
there are aspects of it that yeah are a
little bit
less than i think it could have been i
think those were ultimately what brought
it in because for me the number one was
something that was
you know birds of prey to me was
unexpected stylistically it
did its own thing from front to back so
while i understand it's much more
divisive i really like the cinema style
they were going for i love the energy
throughout the ensemble i
think wonder woman's terrific but i
would just be slightly more compelled
like if i was just gonna kick back and
throw in a dc movie have a good time
it was probably birthday break that is
so
oh thank you for taking the thank you
for taking yeah please my twitter is
that john
let me know how much i am a fake nerd
and i
suck and i hate dc i mean wonder woman
to me
like birds of prey is a movie that we
both get accused of all the time for
lying in our room
just because we liked it i'm just trying
to prove that that review wasn't a lie
yeah because like how some people don't
back off of rumors in
uh certain star wars worlds we're not
going to back off
birds of prey is a really fun like that
to me is easily the most fun
i've had through any of the dc eu movies
and i i do agree with everything you
said
and to me it's like the criticism of
wonder woman is
usually the finale and i'm like well in
my mind birds of break kind of also
falls apart in its finale as well
they seem like they just become the
birds of prey for that purpose at the
end of the day it's like i have way more
fun with birds of parade than i would
say i have
fun with wonder woman but i care
way more when i'm watching i'm swept up
i
cry every freaking time now good these
lists are
set in stone because you're not swaying
me at all in this match
you're not you're not making me reopen
the argument i had with myself when
formulating this
at all yeah i just think uh that's so
funny so
it just looks like yeah like i'm wrong i
thought we were going to give each other
more [ __ ]
no it turns out that minus the first
and last we're pretty close together
really it's the
the only thing i think we could
criticize each other on as a placement
of where you put
wwe 84 where i put justice league
because that's really it
i feel like the rest are pretty tight
and pretty reasonable so if you guys
have a problem with it maybe that's just
you i like them all except for suicide
squad and
uh kind of not really wonder woman i'm
really back and forth on that one
just give it away yeah give it a couple
more days
anyway guys question goes to y'all how
would you rank the dcu movies
where would you rank them let's do this
for marvel next
let me guess man of steel and bvs and
wonder woman are top three
birds of prey and justice league and
suicide squad at the very bottom
and what's in the middle that's really
the debatable partners
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button if you liked it
see you guys
you